if I asked you Michaela do you think
your dad believes in God what would you
say get it
right yeah I think so yeah I do too he
definitely he definitely I I think so he
definitely lives in a way where he knows
that if he acts as if he believes in God
then he avoids hell so I don't know what
the difference between that and belief
is why would you do that if you didn't
believe right
seems reasonable to me right
John sometimes it's always good to bring
out the daughter uh because you'll get
the truth out of the dad you know you
can you can put the old arms up to me
Jordan down there from America but you
can't to your daughter sitting sitting
right next to you she she knows you
better than you probably know yourself
very sneaky plan on your part here